So the other day I was watching
Shang-Chi and I was
Oh my God, why did you do that?
I just didn't like the way
you delivered those lines.
So you punched me in the
freaking face?
So, the other day
So, the
So—
So the other day
I was watching Shang-Chi
and I was so impressed by the
fight sequence on the bus
and how they were able
to make it feel
so visceral and real, without actually
hurting anybody.
I know the punches and kicks aren't real,
but they feel real.
And I wanted to know
how they did it.
So I made a call.
I'm a second unit director
and stunt coordinator.
That's Wade Eastwood.
No relation to other Hollywood Eastwoods.
He's worked on some of the
great action movies
of the past decade
and you can see him right there in 2008’s
Quantum of Solace as
Daniel Craig's stunt double.
Before Wade even takes
a step on set...
he and his team will do a ton of prep
and previsualization.
You might be familiar with VFX
pre-vis thanks to Marvel.
These are the lo-fi animations
they do in advance of
making the movie.
But oftentimes
—stunt teams will do...
—What I call the action vis.
I shoot it live with the proper cameras.
Action vis often looks more like this.
Sets are made of boxes and
stuntmen play the lead roles
as they figure out all the action
and the camera angles
in a safe space.
Then when it comes time to
shoot the movie...
The main unit would shoot the drama
and the acting scenes,
so then I would shoot everything
action-wise with my unit.
Let's break a fight down
to its most basic element...
like a punch.
How do you sell a good
Both sides have to work
the A-side and the B side.
If the person throwing
a stunt punch throws it with a
you know, the best movement and
performance you can have
but the person receiving
it does a really lame reaction...
It doesn't work.
Both parties have to give 100%.
This is important because
the actors and the stunt people
generally aren't actually
hitting each other.
Which can look fake
if you're not "stacking the action"
which is the cool industry term
for saying that
the people and the punching
need to be layered
in a way that cheats the camera.
If we're not stacking the action...
Obviously you can see that
there’s a distance, it's not a sell.
If I'm here suddenly, and you do
a punch and I react
it can come across.
So we have the same gap.
It's just where we put the camera.
It's a couple of inches.
It's, you know, maybe a foot max, depending on what it is.
Sometimes, though, as Michael B. Jordan
explained on the Graham Norton Show
you have to actually make contact
to sell it.
When you do slo-mo shots,
you can't fake it.
You would see the space and it just
wouldn't connect.
This is Michael Jordan taking a real punch:
“And...action!”
The B side of a hit,
AKA the person getting hit,
has all the power
in terms of selling how hard
a punch should be.
So a small hit might
leave me unfazed.
But if I get hit
so if I fall to the ground, it looks
a lot more powerful.
But knowing how to fall correctly
and safely is a whole skill on its own.
If you watch a big car crash
the kinetic energy is breaking down
throughout the whole move.
If that car hits a wall
and stops dead
the driver inside would be dead
because your body cannot
withstand that much impact.
And that's really the thing with falling.
You've got to just do just enough.
The forearm might just absorb a little bit
before the shoulder does,
before the back does
before the whole body does.
And it's 5%, 5%, 5%.
And making sure that you make it
look really gnarly
but you're actually... it's not that gnarly
although obviously sometimes
you are going to hurt yourself,
bruise yourself, pop a rib.
You are going to do something.
But that can be mitigated with
strategically hidden padding...
which you can see right... here,
in this scene from Atomic Blonde.
Though these stairs are supposed to
look like
marble or concrete
this bend indicates that it's a much safer
and softer material.
I use quite a lot of soft materials
where I can.
I’ll have our art department
make something
look exactly like wood or concrete,
whatever it is.
And if we didn't have the padding,
we'd do one or two takes.
It would be really painful.
And you'd probably wouldn't
hit it as hard.
So we put a little bit of high density
absorption in there
and you can hit it much harder
and you can do multiple takes.
And for that brief moment,
the audience get to live that
hard impact with you.
And once that fight goes into
post-production
there are even more tricks used
to make it look like
the hits are just a little bit harder.
Like, that hit looked pretty hard.
But if you cut out the frame where the fist is supposed to make contact,
your brain will fill in the gap and it'll look like
there's just a bit more power to that hit.
You can see this trick used in this shot
from Shang-Chi
where Simu Liu’s elbow
pops on impact.
You can also do things where
visual effects can slightly,
we don't do it, but a lot of movies do,
where you can extend the fist
and actually make it hit the face.
You can see a good example of this
in this clip from No Time to Die,
where the VFX team gave
Ana de Armas digital legs
and they pulled the stunt guy in slightly closer
to get more energy out of the hit.
And of course, the sound design
of a fight scene can add clarity
as to when a swing misses or hits.
And if you took the sound out
of the scene completely...
you wouldn't as easily be able to tell
how softened a blocked kick feels...
or how bone shatteringly hard
a punch feels.
But no matter how cool a fight looks,
it won't feel exciting if there's no stakes.
While I love the Avengers movies,
some of the scenes
where they're just tearing through an army of bad guys
kind of washes over me a little bit.
But then you have something like
Back to the Future
where the whole movie builds to
this one punch
that changes the course of history.
There's a lot of fights that are out there
that are, you know,
great spectacles of fights.
But if you look at why they're fighting
or what it's about,
it's not
there's not really any rhyme or reason.
But when it's a proper fight,
a proper journey, a proper, you know,
bit of emotion
that is when a fight feels exciting.
That is
WHEN a fight feels exciting.
That's when a FIGHT feels exciting.
How was that?
Oh, God, no!
What were you impressed by? Huh?
[laughter]
I was watching Shang-Chi...
I was looking you too dead in the eyes.
[laughs]
...hitting each other.
Sorry, I forgot that I was supposed to punch.
Sorry I’m laughing! You can’t see me right?
Right?
Was that like, too?
I feel like that was maybe too silly.
Cool, right?
I think that's a wrap.